to make a decision like this is a
difficult but was necessary
our Owen five-start is not just
disappointed it
we had much different expectations for
this beginning of the season under
Bill's leadership and the programs he's
gonna put in the discipline and
execution we believe we're giving it the
best opportunity to beat the Miami
Dolphins and for the rest of the year
that's Bruce Allen the president in
Washington not that president different
president but I digress talking about
the firing of Jay Gruden and the
elevation of Bill Callahan to interim
head coach I don't think Bill Belichick
is going to turn this thing around and
Peter he Bruce talks about the
expectations we're better look at their
schedule what were their expectations to
go one in four that's the only
reasonable expectation they could have
had given the roster they have I don't
know how Jay Gruden ends up being the
guy who gets the blame for what occurred
the entire organization has been
dysfunctional for years dating back to
at or about the time Bruce Allen arrived
Mike I would assume that at some point
we are going to hear Jay Gruden say what
the Washington Post reported last week
that the quarterback was the owners
choice it wasn't my choice and and look
we've heard rumors about that since
draft day I asked a few questions about
it during my training camp trip this
summer did not find out enough to report
that so I still don't know I trust the
Washington Post but but let's it let's
just make this point that no matter who
the quarterback was you know was no
matter which quarterback was picked
number one overall if you're the head
coach of the team you got to take a deep
breath you got to swallow hard back in
April and you have to say I'm gonna do
everything in my power to make Dewayne
Haskins a great NFL quarterback and to
get him ready to play because in today's
football basically you get your
quarterback
ready to play so that they can play that
the high picks in that first year and
obviously Dwayne Haskins as the the
result against the giant showed in that
first game that he wasn't altogether
ready and then he wasn't even picked to
start the last game he's not going to
start this week either against Miami
from all indications so I view that as
not just you know the the sort of
water-cooler type of oh man can you
believe Snider picked our quarterback
who cares who picked your quarterback
and I get it that's bad if the owner is
picking the quarterback no question
about it
but at some point you got to wake up and
say I'm gonna make this work we all have
situations at our job that we don't love
and you just get up in the morning and
you say I'm gonna make this work and
that in my opinion is what Jay Gruden
didn't do and Jay Gruden did talk to
ESPN on Monday he said if you're not the
GM you have to accept the fact that you
don't get everything you want you accept
the players given to you
I had input in some areas but there are
some major issues there it's that way
with most coaches you don't have that
total say it's something you have to
overcome and work with the guys you have
so at least after the fact he's sounding
like somebody who understands this is
how it works but Peter even in the teams
where the coach doesn't have final say I
think it's incumbent on the people who
determine the players that will be on
the roster to work with the coach and if
the coach is standing on the table
saying I don't want this guy and you go
get him anyway that's proof positive
that there is dysfunction in the
organization because a properly
functioning football team takes into
account the preferences the likes and
the dislikes of the coach in picking the
players even when the coach doesn't have
the power to pick the players well Mike
this points to I what I said first
shouldn't be mistaken from this is the
way I think the organization should be
run because it isn't this is not the way
an organization should be run did Paul
Allen ever say to John Schneider hey
here's what I want you to do at
quarterback to Stan Kroenke tell Kevin
and les Snead and and that organization
here's who I want you to pick no you
don't do that you don't do that now the
jerry jones thing is different because
jerry jones in essence is the general
manager of this team he and Steven Jones
are gonna decide it but I have been in
that room Mike and I have seen how they
operate and Jerry Jones is not doing
something that his personnel side
doesn't want to do and that his coaching
staff doesn't want to do I've seen it my
whole thing right now very simply is
that when I look at this team I just see
something that from the top down is
totally messed up
why is Bruce Allen still in a position
of authority on a franchise that year
after year is a colossal disappointment
I loved how he set out Doug Williams he
works hard come and check his timecard
I mean is there any general manager or
personnel director in this league who
works a 40-hour week that's what I want
to know point me to one GM or personnel
guy who walks in the front door at nine
o'clock
who walks out at 5:01 and then on the
weekends he takes off who does that
nobody does it don't give your team
credit for working hard I mean look
a clock that tells the wrong time works
hard too and and you know to me when I
look at all this and I listen to him
yesterday in his 13 minutes and and Mike
here's one other little nerdy thing when
I looked at that I mean this is your
first press conference in what four
years you're announcing that you're in
Washington DC you're not in Des Moines
okay and you're announcing that you've
changed coaches and you come out in a
golf shirt and then Bill Callahan comes
on in a long-sleeve coach's t-shirt I
mean what look it's a tiny thing it's a
tiny thing but is it too much to ask
Bruce Allen to wear a coat and tie as
the guy who is standing up
front for the team in the nation's
capital of the United States it just it
just looked also informal hey here we
are we change coaches we threw Jay
Gruden away I mean it's just it's not
run the right way well let's hear and
see some more from Bruce Allen in his
golf shirt from yesterday talking about
the culture of the organization here's
Bruce Allen you know the culture is
actually damn good these people care we
have got very young core players that we
have brought in here who are accustomed
to winning if you look at the record of
these guys they're accustomed to winning
they want to win and free agency we
brought Landon Collins a great leader
great player wants to win we haven't put
it together we've made too many mistakes
on game day but the effort the effort of
the players and the rest of this
organization is fantastic this so much
in that one little snippet Peter too
many mistakes on game day
hello Jay Gruden we've not only fired
you we are blaming it all on you because
it's only on game day when things go
wrong and this idea that we're bringing
in free agents that are accustomed to
winning and he points to Landon Collins
did he play for the Patriots am I not am
i damn I have the Giants been markedly
better than my eyes would tell me over
the past few years it's just ridiculous
and if we're going to talk about records
Bruce Allen the years that he's been in
charge of the football operation without
Scott McLuhan there 42 and 75 is the
team's record under Bruce Allen that
gets anyone else that gets everyone else
fired from that job yeah I don't really
understand in the first few years of
running this team in this organization
Daniel Snyder
basically you know was lapping people
off every year and now all of a sudden
he has got incredibly patient with
everybody there's one thing if you have
patience with people who are getting the
job done
you know he's now got a front office of
people not
getting the job done in my opinion Mike
I just I don't understand what exactly
has happened with this organization I
don't think anybody got a theory and
either this I got a theories I got a
theory should go please here's my theory
my theory is this at some point over the
last ten years Daniel Snyder has decided
that the only thing better than being
rich and famous is being rich and he has
faded out of that that that spotlight
that target that he dealt with for ten
years as the reviled owner of the team
that he grew up loving so he's basically
made Bruce Allen the surrogate owner
Bruce Allen's the guy who shows up at
the tough press conferences Bruce Allen
is the guy who's going to take all the
criticism Snyder just owns the team and
he's not the face of the team he's
hiding in the corner and I don't mean
that in a pejorative sense he's choosing
to stay in the shadows that sounds a
little less a little less mean but he
doesn't want to have anything to do with
it so Bruce Allen's the guy and Bruce
Allen's not going anywhere because of it
because without Bruce Allen you need
another surrogate owner and until Daniel
Snyder finds someone else to fill that
role it's gonna be Bruce Allen and Bruce
Allen is not going to be held
accountable even though he should be
look I don't say this lightly because
you know I've covered the NFL for 35
years
and I my first job covering the NFL was
in Cincinnati so I understand the regard
or lack thereof that the denizens of
southwestern Ohio have for Mike Brown
and the brown family who run the Bengals
he is turned into mostly a reviled
figure in Cincinnati and the environs
and by the the you know those who would
love the Bengals across the country
there aren't many of those by the way
but I have to say right now that in all
ways right now Daniel Snyder is the most
loathed owner by his fans of any owner
in the NFL and perhaps of any owner of
any sports team in the United States and
if you just look
at what happened on Sunday in that
Stadium with the New England Patriots
basically making more noise far and away
than the Washington fans did and looking
at the composition of the crowd you know
where there were people in seats which
wasn't you know it wasn't overwhelming
in that Stadium and that Stadium more
and more is looking like a mausoleum I
mean Dan Snyder for his own good really
aw sell the team he just should this is
a total embarrassment to have the team
in your nation's capital be so hated
so reviled that everyone Scott Simon the
respected voice of NPR he I forget what
his tweet was yesterday but he tweeted
something about Snyder that was so ugly
and so disrespectful that I say this is
Scott Simon of national and I just you
know Mike you know at some point you
know somebody I don't know who it is has
to say the Daniel Snyder it's over
Johnny well it's over for now we're
gonna take a quick break when we return
the Colts beat the Chiefs on Sunday
night Peter spoke to Colts coach Frank
Reich about how they did it
Peter will tell you what he learned when
PFT live continue to Netflix
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports